I’d like to make a distinction between the
techniques known as image processing, and
the techniques known as computer vision.
Image processing is a technique that takes
an image and produces another image. It’s
often used for image enhancement. In this
example we see a medical image where features
within the body are rather indistinct, and
by applying an image processing technique
to it, they have been enhanced. They have
higher contrast and it is easier to see the
wires and other structures inside the body.
Computer vision, on the other hand, or machine
vision as it’s sometimes called, takes an
image and produces features. What we see here
is an input image with a large number of coloured
pixels. Some are yellow, some are grey, some
are blue. And what it’s producing on the
right-hand side are features which describe
just the yellow objects. And we can see here
that we’ve highlighted the centres of those
objects, and we’ve also put red boxes around
them that show their spatial extent. So we’ve
reduced the amount of information from a whole
lot of colour pixels to a bunch of quite succinct
information for coordinates of centres and
the coordinates of the corners of four bounding
boxes.
That pertinent information we refer to as
image features and there are really three
different kinds of image features that are
in common use. The first one is regions; the
example that I just gave. For each of these
yellow objects, I might be interested in knowing
where’s their centre, how big are they,
what shape are they, what’s the orientation.
Are they pointing sideways, are they pointing
vertically. And there are other features that
we could use to describe the shape of these
yellow objects.
Another kind of very common feature are lines.
And lines are everywhere. certainly in the
built environment. So we might be interested
in what are the equations of these dominant
lines in the image. We might be interested
in the start and end points of these lines,
the line segments that perhaps might delineate
an area of a roof or the edge of a building.
The last kind of feature that we use in computer
vision are points. Here what I’ve done is
overlaid onto a picture of a building what
are called interest points. These are points
that contain a lot of information and would
be easy to find in another view of that same
building. So the circles indicate the centre
of these interest points and the size of the
circle says something about the scale of those
interest points. Now, interest points and
the scale of points is not something we’re
going to cover in this lecture series, but
certainly it’s a topic about which there
is a lot of literature, and they are a very
important concept in modern computer vision.
Let’s go back again and consider region
features, which is what we are going to talk
about in this lecture. A question you might
like to ask is where are the symbols on this
sign; where are the letters and the other
graphical elements. Well if we find region
features we are able to solve this problem.
And what I’ve done here with a bit of quite
simple code, is to put a bounding box around
each of the distinct white symbols on this
otherwise black sign.